Species are decided
the moment they're born,
so they want a purpose they can accept.
You're a tough one to chew on.
This will be the end, kid.
Yes, I agree.
I've started to realize, Jack,
the purpose of being born a wolf.
I probably shouldn't be
showing this to you.
I'm sorry, Hal.
There's nothing to be afraid of.
These nails are for you.
These fangs are for you.
I'll be your beast.
Do I look like a devil to you?
Hal. It's all right now.
You're free to decide.
Would you run away with me?
Legoshi.
Would you tame this gray wolf?
My body's shivering.
I'm glad.
Really.
Legoshi.
I came this far wanting to be forgiven...
for the fact that I was born a carnivore.
That I'm in love with you.